it is a crisp winter morning in the
English Channel
these waters in sight of the lights of
Brixham and Devon are heavily contested
the French wanna beer the Belcher's want
to be in the Dutch wanna beer they all
want to be it on there but as the crew
of the trawler the girl Deborah dropped
their nets they're hoping it will be
brexit that delivers their biggest catch
in decades the years British fishing has
been in decline skipper
Dave driver says now is the chance for a
new beginning
hopefully it's a big change for the
industry a lot of fishermen I hope and
it's gonna be a big change because we've
been sold down the river you know 40
years ago by E so we just want a bit of
what what is what is ours back the
fishermen here say they should be able
to catch more and it's unrealistic for
Brussels to think it can continue with
the status quo we think a raw deal
obviously we think we should have more
quota not for the French and the
Belgians they've got a lot more crow
than we got yes they've got a bigger
fishing fleet but it's in our water and
if we could get the six mile extenders
as well smaller boats like this prospero
it may seem odd for an island nation but
under current arrangements 60% of
British fish is caught by the European
fleet although fishing plays only a tiny
part in the UK economy it has had an
outsized role in the whole brexit saga
yes on one level it's about catching
fish it's about competition for the
European fleet and the issue of quotas
but it's much more than that for levers
what happens on this boat is less about
what comes up in the next and more about
what it signifies and that is the
restoration of sovereignty
fishing for a seafaring nation touches
the national psyche but romance and
nostalgia may have to be pushed aside a
Brixham market last night's catches up
for auction
but frictionless trade remains important
for this part of the business we have
some fears because of the the borders
and things like that but we're hoping we
can work with our European partners in
making sure that this fish ends up it is
final destination because the majority
of this fish does end up on our European
friends plates and that is the brexit
conundrum
it may be for UK negotiators that access
to the EU is more important than keeping
European fishermen out of British waters
the fishing industry is the acid test of
Boris Johnson's government in number 10
the industry was sacrificed in the early
70s for other objectives of government
so it's entirely for Whitehall and
government departments to decide where
their priorities are and the industry
could be sacrificed again and that
industry which voted overwhelmingly in
favor of brexit will soon find out if
the promises made by politicians will be
honored but if quotas and fishing rights
are linked to a wider trade deal they
may not end up with what they voted for
Alex Rossi skynews rixel